[Music]
i'm the one only mvp michael venom page
entertaining unusual unique i like to do
stuff that doesn't necessarily make
sense
[Applause]
i think i'm one of the toughest men on
the planet it may not always be pretty
but damn it you can't beat me we'll see
if he ever comes forward at all
i want to go in there i want to land
shots and not be touched i'm more a
sniper like i said man if he's there at
the end of it well he'll be bleeding
connor
the crummy town bomber
[Applause]
[Music]
seven
[Music]
[Music]
please don't get involved
what is popping thick boys the girls the
kids the grandpas thick aunts thick gay
uncles we all just think out there man
it's a thick boy summer it's coming to
an end isn't it when summer officially
over chin i don't even know august
is it sometime in august or september
1st
when is summer over
september 22nd okay we got a little bit
of ways to go
summer is not even close to be well we
have about a month and a half huh mm-hmm
what is the 15th yeah we got about a
month month and a week
it's getting starting to get really hot
now too oh it's getting spicy out there
it is god damn toasty your boy went on a
bike ride in a run yesterday
about two three mile run just shy of
three so won't say three that's not fair
and then about 15 mile bike ride and i
didn't bring any water
um
i gotta get my thick ass in shape for
the tough mudder on august 27th in
chicago i assume it's gonna be hot out
there
i assume it's gonna be goddamn
scorching out there
um
so i decided to go out in a 100 degree
weather in the middle of the mountains
in california with no water and it was a
bad idea
i started throwing up
so i thought i didn't eat all day i fast
on the weekends and i it was two o'clock
by the time i went on this bike ride
just look at my i mean look at my
[ __ ] tongue
it looks dry dry oh my god the tongue of
a parrot dude it's just dry cracked i
literally started throwing up but
throwing up nothing like the worst thing
to do and then my abs started uh
cramping it was insane but i made it
home got some electrolytes shout out to
uh what i use i use the liquid iv yeah
the orange one boom you're pointing back
in action with the kiddos after that
thick daddy's coming up yeah i got to
get my thick ass in shape for the uh the
tough mudder on the 27th
oh that's my son's singing freaking uh
journey does he do that a lot does he
sing oh my god dude non-stop you might
have a singer maybe dude he
loves it he is his favorite song in the
freaking world is freaking journey
trippy just a knockdown girl but the
thing is the one he watches it's live in
houston you know born and raised in
south detroit but he goes born raising
right here in houston all he thinks is
it's houston oh and he look when he goes
like this is when he goes houston
like right dude
you're getting the wrong song
but uh yeah first day of preschool now
here's where it gets dicey the first day
of preschool in that fire ass outfit
that was he was styled by his dad i'm
his kanye he's my kim right and uh
some fresh air force ones okay fresh air
force one's flexing on the kids for a
sneaker day and then he has calves like
his mom he's those big moana calves and
then uh
he's gonna miss the rest of the week of
school because he's going to montana so
so we'll see you know he's not the best
brad didn't plan that too well oh you
have enjoy your first day of school and
then you're going to miss the entire
week and then come back while everybody
else made friends and you're going to be
on your own you'll figure it out though
dude you figure it out
you figure out he's he's pissed cause he
went to the car show with someone uh dm
me a new car show that's in malibu and
it's small and it's from seven to nine
when they say seven nine they mean seven
to nine
so we stopped at starbucks about eight
fifty got the round nine ten there was
three cars in the parking lot
three cars there was a 918 uh carrera so
that made it worth it so that's dope but
yeah if you if you know of any new
or even older uh
car shows popping up around california
let your boy know
my kids are not happy dude it makes me
look like a bad father
yeah is the silver one the crowd gt it's
right you uh going for about 1.8 right
now 1.8 mil
when someone goes down once you buy them
you're out your goddamn mind dude you
have no clue what the hell you're
talking about that car's fantastic
instrument doesn't move on the fights
what's interesting about those is when
they first came out nobody wanted them
everyone made fun of them oh the way
they look yeah just everything you're
like what the hell but
now they are regretting it because if
you could have got that thing at msrp
you it would be a great investment
porsche 19 spider they're so dope it
looks so good yeah
is that the one that spins out of
control real easy no okay no no
no that's good then yeah
you're referring to the widowmaker the
996 gt2 rs it's obvious those things are
a problem
rogan has one
souped up from sharks works
but rogaine drives his ass off and he
doesn't drive like a dumbass
but they're filthy
996 gt turbo
uh it'd be a
996 gt2 rs is referred to as the
widowmaker sometimes
996 997
yeah those are if you get your hands on
one of those you're doing pretty good
all right thickies ufc 278 is here and
it is action packed that's right you
have the camaro usually versus edwards
rematch in the main event throw down and
grab your own epic victory with
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner the ufc this saturday
new customers can bet just five dollars
and get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly win or lose if that's not
enough action for you you can also get a
ten dollar risk free same game parlay
just combine multiple bets like which
fighter will come out on top how long
will the fight last and so much more
listen man i told you
now that i'm saying picking all these
guys would be a fun parlay to bet on all
the underdogs you got leon edwards is a
dog you got luke rockhold dog jose aldo
dog the three of them parley we go win
sizzler daddy the three dogs ain't a bad
bat download the dragon sportsbook app
right now use the promo code shop show
bet five dollars on ufc 278 and get two
hundred dollars in free bets instantly
that's coach schaub show this saturday
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports band partner the ufc minimum age
eligibility restriction supply see show
notes for details see next page for
directional for disclaimer
download draftking sportsbook app right
now use prom code shop show you had some
fights this weekend you had a fight
night in san diego california
a home game for the legend will the best
ever do it
merry garma is the best bantamweight
fighter of all time wc champ ufc champ
commentator the dude is mamba mentality
dominick cruz
um this is a tough one for me because
i'm close with cheeto cheetos my boy
cheeto i re regarded as a friend i love
cheetos his story is fantastic he's been
the ufc for a hot second and it's just
his time and i think he got dominic cruz
right at the perfect time
um
you know by root for dominic cruz just
like i'm gonna root for jose aldo this
saturday uh you'll see 278 right you'll
see 278. it's stuff not the root for
these legends kind of re
on a resurgence path to
to a title shot you know if dom won this
you'd have to give him a title because
dominic cruz donald cruz is impossible
to beat impossible to ko impossible to
finish
um he only loses the guys that are
either champs former champs or their
next fight they're fighting the champ so
for cheeto taking on dominic cruz all
the chips were stacked against him
and even stylistically not ideal for for
vera i was watching his family and
friends and obviously dominic cruz came
out like a goddamn banshee he looked
good after three acl surgeries you know
the guy's a you know
he's just a warrior man he's done a lot
of work on himself to get back there and
if anybody needs acls it's dominick cruz
with his movement his footwork his
angles nobody
uh
needs movement more for their
fight style than domit cruz that guy is
predicated on a fight style that
requires a lot of footwork a lot of
angles a lot of movement unorthodox
movement you know he's a pioneer man a
lot of people have
taken his stylenet to their own you look
at you know even guys that have beat him
or he's beat look at tj dillashaw his
style pretty close to domi cruz not
exactly but he's definitely a splash of
dominic cruz you look at um
you know certain guys that are in the
bantamweight division not you know
travis brown for that matter had a very
similar style with his movement you know
there's a lot of guys
um who else am i forgetting you look at
uh what's his name
my boy why am i forgetting his [ __ ]
name
um
he cut weight lost now he's back oh cody
cody garbrandt cody garbrandt very
similar style now is it to a t no but it
is
you know domino cruz did start a trend
he was the first one to do it being a
wrestler um and then incorporating that
kind of movement into mixed martial arts
he changed the game man he changed the
game similar to steph curry and how the
nba has changed to you know long
uh
long-range shots you know that's dominic
cruz what he's done has really changed
the game for the better so hats off
donna cruz
this was a tough one for me because i do
love dominic cruz i think he's one of
the most if not the most brilliant mind
to ever fight you know he is the the
the closest thing we have to kobe bryant
fighting in the ufc he just has that you
know kill or be killed mentality he's
gonna do everything it takes to win a
fight um all he cares about is fighting
and you look at his personal life you
know this dude all he gives a flying
[ __ ] about is fighting he's obsessed
with it
so i root for that guy man and you know
for for cheeto and dom cruise too for
cheeto he's had a few key moments in his
career he looked at his fight against
jose aldo kind of his first big test he
didn't really pull the trigger sat back
too long and he turned it on at the end
of the fight but a little too late to
you know
he just didn't get it done and i think
he learned from that and it set him up
for success against these other legends
like domi cruz obviously he had the win
over uh sugar shawn which is big
feathers cap but this was kind of a make
or break for both guys you know because
for
cheeto
right he
loses seong yong dong
now that we know what sung young dung is
about that's nothing to hang your head
about and that was fight of the night
not to mention then you get sugar shawn
say what you want beat sugar shawn uh
and then you give him jose aldo jose was
kind of his first really big test he
didn't pass that test so it's like all
right well let's go back to the drawing
board for a lot of guys i think they
would be like all right maybe i'm just
not at that level but after that
cheeto goes on to rip off three wins in
a row and out of those three wins you
know one of them is frankie yeager
another legend which brutal front kick
ko in the third round got performance of
the night fight before that is fight of
the night fight right after that rob
font uh misses wait and then you know he
beats him as a main event again
uh joe zaldo lost all right let's see
how he reacts
beats davey grant fight of the night
then okay
maybe he is there here's frankie edgar
another legend another tough guy to beat
tough guy to finish
ko front kick savage performance of the
night oh [ __ ] all right here's your
first main event here's a main event
against rob font no punk dude guy puts
out you know puts out some volume man
it's gonna be tough
destroys rob font i mean that was a
mercy rule fight he absolutely destroyed
rob font gets by the night there okay
maybe we can invest in cheeto here's
dominic cruz and now not only find
dominic cruz coming off a huge win over
pedro munoz but
here's dominic cruz in his backyard in
san diego all the chips against you
you know
depend how you judge fights and
obviously
the number one thing we know the number
one criteria that the judges are
supposed to judge on is damage inflicted
now in those first two rounds you would
say first three rounds you would say
one and two
dom had takedowns did the most
output had a higher output but
cheeto did drop them which would be the
most damage inflicted but still i i
think overall he's probably down two
rounds going to the third i think he
wins the third so he's down 2-1 on the
cards going to the fourth
and i'm watching a family and friends
and my girl kept saying ah cruising beat
him via decision i have no no no no
cheeto's a slow start dom is a super
fast starter dom doesn't if dom knows
you're a slow starter he comes at you
like a [ __ ] banshee there's nobody
better at game playing than dominic cruz
i'm telling you he's a monster but the
best thing about cheeto is he hits like
a mac [ __ ] truck and when he does hit
he makes it count and he's just
downloading the data he's downloading
data very similar to what floyd
mayweather would do especially older in
his career as he came more experienced
he would let guys kind of get off on him
a little bit he was a slow starter now
as he's slow starters he's just
downloading the data remember there's a
five round fight so that favors cheeto
especially with his fighting style so
cheetos download the data now you
download the data of dominic cruz who
it's very rare he does the same thing
twice he mixes up he throws faints he's
in he's out you give him to the cage
which i thought for cheeto was
very important to capitalize when uh
cruz was against the cage as soon as
foot hit that black line in my head i'm
like if i'm cheetos team i'm saying this
is where you need to capitalize when his
foot hits that black line this dude's
all over the goddamn place you got it
that's where you hone in and fire off
first two rounds couldn't get the timing
cheeto's downloading down even though he
threw that double jab straight right
which lit dominic cruz up you know he's
still down on the cards i think two to
one won the third fourth it's you know
it's not that crew slowed down but
cheeto download more download more
download more and then you can see it i
said it's the first round of my girl and
and my father-in-law went notice every
time dom cruise gets out his head is
down his head's way to the side whether
it's left to right he's giving out it's
fast but if cheeto can time that it
could be a problem it's also kind of old
school gotta be honest even though his
style changed the game for the better it
is an older style and guys are more
previewed to what's going on here and
they're going to capitalize if you're
swaying to one side or the other so dom
cruz goes to get out like he always does
and has been very successful doing it it
finally caught up with him
because cheeto throws that left high
kick and kicks him right in the [ __ ]
face i don't mean like some like nic
usually you see one of those kicks like
kind of graze a face or maybe the foot
will wrap around the back of the head
and you know the equilibriums off no no
no no not only did he kick him directly
in the face he shattered his goddamn
nose and you're talking about ufc
royalty
so for cheeto
you know he's not a guy that talks trash
really these two had some bad blood
going into it but
you know
in this day and age guys get on the mic
and they tell you'll see what they want
to do
i think for cheeto it's a little murky
because you have so much going on there
man you in that division it's like it's
not very clear i think cheeto could have
asked for a title shot and i don't think
any of us would argue with it
beating frank yeager right horrible k
over frankie and then aft doing what
nobody's ever been able to do donna cruz
i think he deserves a title shot only
problem there is you'll be waiting a hot
second you got algebraic sterling and tj
dilshaw fighting right
maybe get the winner of that but then
you also got peter yawn and freaking um
sugar shawn o'malley fighting you also
have corey santa hagan and uh sung young
dung fighting so there's this kind of
gamut tournament in the bantamweight
division where cheeto can be put in
there so
i would assume what happens with cheeto
depending what goes on with a sterling
tj dill shawl fight i would assume
cheeto gets the winner of sugar sean
peter yan
sugar could definitely win that fight it
was an underdog you win that fight
all i'm saying is for my money peter yan
verscito is a goddamn fight of the year
written all over it
but to the latter of that if sugar shawn
were to get it done it becomes
top five biggest stars in the ufc a
rematch with sugar and cheeto ain't too
bad either
there's no bad fights for for cheeto the
only the only one that kind of [ __ ]
things up of course samhain starches
song young dung
then you'd probably do corey versus
cheeto that's that probably though now
this you know cory's from my hometown
he's a yeah i've been with that kid
since he was [ __ ] 15 came into
my uh
high altitude martial arts as a
basketball player now to see him ranked
in the [ __ ] top five's insane to me
um so i always root for corey but as far
as star power and you know
cheetos career that would be worst case
for him
you know but never bad i really think uh
he's gonna get the winner of peter yan
and um
sugar shawn and then winner of that
fights cheeto then the winner of cheeto
peter yan or uh suga gets the title shot
we want sizzler
at that division the bantamweight is
fantastic i can't get enough
overall great fight card great [ __ ]
fight card and dc kept saying how
electric the crowd was he's like i've
been through a lot of these man i've
never i've never felt anything like in
san diego san diego crowds are fantastic
when they want to be they lost the
chargers because they have no energy and
have too many options but
and then you bring it up and they get
all pissed um
you know but marlon vera had you know
a lot to
a lot of pressure on him to perform
because the two fights before that and
really
the whole main card was fantastic
mershot uh looked fantastic against
bruno silva to get the submission and
then uh you had a tko after that in the
first round one minute in uh devin clark
got
you know tough fight for him against uh
osmot who's a [ __ ] monster at light
heavyweight again these guys are coming
in these russians daggers staying coming
in i keep telling you guys coming in
learn how to pronounce their name
brendan i'm telling you invest time in
it and i'm a devin clark fan dude with
his wrestling background he has a
milwaukee bucks tattoo on his chest so
that's lit he's giant for the division
i feel like he could fight it
heavyweight if you want to would have
some significant advantages there so you
know
osmot's the real deal man he's a [ __ ]
tough customer man very tough customer
um
you know and then uh going right before
the co-main event uh the yasmin vs
lasmin yasmin vs lasman two debuts two
debuts saw people saying greatest debuts
of all time
i think people got caught up in the
moment um going around great fight
they both have so much potential both of
them have great ufc careers the skill
wise they're both young anyone's 20 the
others like 21 very young first rights
in the ufc
um you know
not five year i thought people got a
little
uh out of control i think i think people
got caught up in the moment you know the
fight card was insane and that was a
good fight but come on the best debut
we've ever seen this is ridiculous
oh really
thought it was good
i thought it was good if you think it
was better than that co-main event nate
uh lander landwear nate landriver's
david onama you're out of your goddamn
mind that was straight-up fight of the
year
those featherweight boys nate from the
dana white uh contender series said
hold my bear ladies i'm going to work
daddy and he's must see tv he's no now
at featherweight is he a top 10 guy no
god no he's not there yet the skills
aren't there and david onama is going to
have a very tough time because he got
broke in the second round you know so
when i see a guy break this early it's
gonna be a tough go for it man
very tough go but there's guys who
break early and then learn to work on
their mental aspect of it and maybe that
scares them you know you look a guy like
sam alvey you know obviously last night
in a row that's awful but he was a guy
who ultimate fighter quit broke you know
so
you know he figured out how to
you know
iron out those demons and had a decent
career and you couldn't break that guy
inside that octagon but you know david
onama there was some quit there which is
alarming but that fight was fantastic
and then they gets on the mic and rips i
thought an awkward promo
that was a little awkward but man
he put some pressure on marlon vera to
cheeto to [ __ ] perform and you know
marlon vera donald cruz was a great it's
weird to go from
[Music]
you know yasmin and lasman their debuts
and nate uh landware and david onama and
then don't get me wrong they're fun
fights but to
go from those
two fights into the tip of the spear and
uh cheeto and dominic cruz there's just
a difference in there there's it's like
your tv got brighter you know what i'm
saying it's like you even if you're
watching on a [ __ ] tv you still have
that for hd when cheeto and dominic cruz
perform man it was a fantastic fight
good fight
game of inches man and [ __ ] that kick
dude my word that [ __ ] kick so
hats off to our boy cheeto man he's
doing the goddamn thing
he's doing the goddamn thing we gotta
get him on a uh
on a fight campaign i'm trying he might
go to um
salt lake city that's where you'll see
278's at this weekend now this saturday
it's a busy time for your boy now i am
going on vacation this week uh but i hit
the ground running because i come back
friday
well my family stays there because daddy
has work to do right dad don't have to
pay for that vacation so um daddy comes
back early i hit the ground running
friday with a food truck and a special
guest and then saturday
we start off with a fight campaign the
first one ever for bkfc in london at 11
a.m it's one of the biggest bkfc's ever
um you have michael venom page versus
mike perry
since they announced this everyone's
been excited about it and the co-main
event is paige vanzant
um versus another uh only fans star
cigla cigar segala
um she's 38 so obviously time is not in
her favor she's one and two pages oh and
two but both of them are bigger than
their records you know um i'm excited
for this fight always excited when paige
fights paige is an interesting one
because she doesn't need to fight she
makes so much goddamn money off her only
fans it's really not even to our only so
there's only fans then paige said no no
i'm gonna do my own thing and launch her
own website with her own only fans
content just so she owns all of it it's
brilliant brilliant paige is a great
career man
so
you know we're doing a fight command 11
a.m on saturday then we're also doing
another fight command completely
different crew at 7 pm pacific on thick
boy so the the bare knuckle fighting
championship
in london will take place with myself
bert kreischer and matt matrione at 11
a.m on saturday on thick boy youtube
burt is one of my favorite [ __ ]
people on the planet and uh i absolutely
love the guy and he is so fun so we're
gonna be drinking early on saturday for
the bare knuckle uh
fighting championship with uh michael
venom page and mike perry with bert
kreicher and matt matrione and then come
on back because thick boy is doing the
fight campaign cowbest fight campaign
for ufc 278 i will announce those guests
very soon that's gonna be a fun one as
well uh but this card i listen i was
like i originally the plan wasn't to do
two fighting pains but
i'm solo family's out of town what else
am i gonna do i'm gonna watch it anyways
might as well watch with the boys the
crew here and some very fun guests
uh and it's a great card the main card
is fantastic kicks off with tyson pedro
my brother from a very australian mother
we've done a shoei together so we're
basically brothers um harry hunsucker
he's fighting him you know great fight
for tyson pedro he's been off for a hot
second but i'm definitely taking tyson
pedro on that and then next up you have
uh martin tibera versus alexander
romanov
romanov right looks like roman again
he's savage i think he's undefeated but
tough fight for your boy tybera very
tough fight i can't see this going to
the judge's scorecards to be undefeated
i don't give a [ __ ] where you're
fighting at to be a heavyweight and go
on to feed this long you're doing
something right you're doing something
right and this boy gets finishes
he had one split decision other than
that though um
[Music]
it's uh he's a savage man
efc heavyweight champion to be was he 60
yeah 16 no nuts he beat chase sherman
which is no punk veranda yep he
tough fight for uh
tibera very tough fight
uh and then we get into the nitty-gritty
of it you have some superstars on this
card which one i'm excited for it yeah
jose aldo versus marab
valeshvili valshili
[Music]
so the d is just silent huh you kind of
say it's valesville vallasili bala's
jewish that's a fun one jose versus
vallashili
um room for my boy jose i think he's won
three in a row since um you know one of
those wins over cheeto
and uh there you go so he beat cheeto
pedro munoz and rob font what are we
doing here yeah this fight against peter
young was
fantastic um
you know he's a savage man he's one of
the greatest ever [ __ ] do it
um
again vashili and some of these other
russians and dagestands and valashilis
from where ah dark i forgot he's a
savage
georgia george got a nose on him
georgian yeah i mean all that like
eastern europe it's just the rather a
[ __ ] problem all right they're a
goddamn problem
um
yeah of course she's a
black belt in combat combat [ __ ]
it's just what they do dude
he's a problem
he is a problem man but i do think jose
aldo gets it done i think it's too much
too soon for vashili rooting for jose
auto just like i
you know it's tough not to root for
these legends man but i do think josiah
gets it done
um and the co-maid event is fantastic
the co-main event i bet gets more
attention than the main event just
because paulo costa and luke rockhold
will talk some [ __ ] they will talk [ __ ]
all day they've been talking [ __ ] paulo
costa oh he's lost his last two luke
rockhold hasn't had a win in hot second
um but luke rockhold's so goddamn
talented
when luke was in here you know you can
just tell the focus that he has on this
fight he's dead serious about it he's
running he's late to the [ __ ]
campaign because he took shrooms and
just went running and lost track of time
you know he has his diet on point um
i know he's underdog in this i'm taking
luke rockhold i think he gets it done i
really do um now bisping had some
interesting say he was saying on bt
sport which is my favorite thing to
watch on bt sport
that you know he's very close with
luke's trainer um at ruka
and he was saying that the the trainer
there was telling him that uh luke
hasn't really done sparring like
he he's he's training hard but as hard
as you would like which is a little
alarming but also if you're luke coming
from those aka days i get why you're not
gonna spar so much you know i get it
he's had some bad knockouts too so hell
yeah good microfirst head yeah agree
could be good so you know on this on
this fight card if you if you're with me
like the dogs um
you make some money man parlaying jose
aldo parlaying luke rockhold and then
having camaro spin or if you're really
really
feeling froggy you bet on all the dogs
leon edwards luke rocco and jose aldo i
could see all of them winning i really
can listen we got to take a little break
from me chatting your ear off about
fisticuffs because listen
your boy is getting in shape i have a
tough mudder august 27th in chicago and
one of the ways i like to get in shape
is by riding my bike but i need good
headphones you guys make fun of me i'll
post selfies on the trails next to
rattlesnakes hanging out with
rattlesnakes i'm friends with a lot of
rattlesnakes and you guys make fun of my
because i have wires on my freaking
earbuds i don't my ears are weird i
haven't found a wireless one that works
for me and then my friends at raycon
raycon wireless earbuds said you know
what we got you daddy raycon's everyday
earbuds look feel and sound better than
ever with optimized gel tips for the
perfect air in fit that's what i'm
talking about that's why they work for
your boy here these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me i freaking tear down the
mountain i'd never worry about them and
here's my favorite part of raycons they
give you eight hours of playtime a
32-hour battery life y'all raycons are
priced just right you get quality auto
at half the price of other premium audio
brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over fifty thousand five
star reviews i can't get enough of it
myers are weird i listen to music
podcasts i talk when i'm uh riding my
bike or working out these are the only
earbuds i will endorse all right go to
buy raycon.com shop s-c-h-a-b today you
get 50 off your raycon order that's by
raycon.com job to score 15 off by raycon
r-a-y-c-o-n dot com
shop s-c-h-a-u-b
these are the best earbuds i've ever had
by byraycon.com shop
man one of my buddies close friend i
won't say who but they got hacked man
and i just don't mean like hacked like
someone broke into their instagram i'm
talking about their bank info got hacked
their freaking email got hacked and it
is scary man and i thought to myself
that could happen to anybody it's always
been a concern about mine fill out so
much personal stuff online i'm ordering
stuff
address here
freaking billing info here credit card
info here between my family and my busy
life i got enough to worry about already
i need a peace of mind i need some
identity protection man but how do i
even know where to start what do i need
here all right and listen my friends at
allstate said
say less daddy allstate identity
protection the best identity protection
from a brand you can trust i have
allstate for all my other insurance but
guess what
they're doing
protecting you online man the internet
knows a lot about you but doesn't have
to with allstate digital footprint see a
list of your online accounts track where
you've been online learn how companies
are using your data if your personal
information has been exposed in a data
breach and get tips to proactively
protect your privacy and identity this
stuff's important all right and allstate
identity protection even includes dark
web monitoring with ai and human sourced
intelligence provide an extra layer of
detection they got you dudes all right
with aip they'll reimburse you up to 1
million buckaroos for out-of-pocket
expenses lost wages legal fees they also
cover money stolen from your bank
accounts 401ks hsas and tax returns not
only will allstate monitor help keep you
safe but should identify theft ever
occur their u.s based customer care
identity specialists provide expert
support 24 7 365 days a year all right
you got a team behind you now with an
industry leading 98 satisfaction score
think that the idea of protection your
bank provides is enough think again it's
not the reality is that most financial
institutions act only after fraud occurs
rather than preventing it they're just
responding to it you got to be proactive
you're not reactive with this fraud you
don't want to react to fraud you want to
be proactive man that's where allstate
comes in having comprehensive monitoring
coverage from aip will make sure you can
stop identity thieves in their tracks
before any major damage is done plus aip
can even monitor your social media
ensure no one takes over your accounts
all right what i love about all style
allstate identity protection is i have a
peace of mind of course i have a digital
footprint out there of course some of my
info's out there but i'm not worried
about it because my friends at allstate
are working 24 7 and they're not
reacting i don't call them go hey i
think no they're they're putting out the
fire buff even starts man all right
don't let don't be reacting to when your
stuff gets hacked be proactive that's
where allstate comes into play here so
when you think about identity protection
think allstate identity protection to
find out if your employer offers
all-state identity protection head to
aip.com
if not cool get a 30-day free tr free
trial at
aip.com one last time that's aip.com
s-c-h-a-u-b
be proactive
uh the main event kermit who's been our
pound for pound number one in the sport
in the ufc camaro usman
um what's scary about them is now they
fought before right they fought before
and camaro beat them via decision
but i don't put too much emphasis in
that first fight both guys have changed
so much leon edwards has gotten better
at wrestling and even his mma striking
has gotten better since then
kamarusam when he fought leona edwards
you're talking about a straight up
wrestler fighting leon edwards
now camaro's game is completely
different he has more confidence in his
striking he's worked with trevor whitman
he's worked with the you know um uh
tomboy's name that he worked with before
that um henry hoof he's worked with
henry hoof who doesn't get enough credit
but he's working with henry hoof he's
really downed in this boxing with trevor
whitman who i started with i know how
much of a [ __ ] magician trevor
whitman is
so kamar usman now
you know this is very similar like leon
edwards isn't a knockout artist leona
edwards is a technician probably the
best striking in welterweight division
as far as putting it all together goes
you know he's won 10 in a row some [ __ ]
like that leonardo is a goddamn savage
you see why did nate diaz but
you know some of those rounds are 10-8
but the the narrative on that is he got
clipped in the you know last 30 seconds
the fifth round
which wasn't ideal for leon or the ufc
but i do think uh this is a case of
you know
can i see lyanna we're winning 100
percent i think it's going to be karma
usman's
second toughest challenge i do think
kobe covington
gives kamar usman the toughest challenge
because of his style because because of
the the the way he puts pressure on
the his skill set his wrestling
background uh his cardio they're
so if there's if you're listening cardio
in the wet weight division kermar
usman's 1a kobe comes into 1b leonardo
says good cardio but not like those guys
um
so i do think this fight will be a
matter of leon edwards if he can control
the narrative as far as kamar usman not
pressure him against the cage and lock
him against the cage um i see kamal
getting a finish i don't think he goes
all five
i don't think it goes all five i think
kamal finishes them
i think edwards also will be surprised
how much better camaro has gotten
at the art of striking and i think
kamara lands some big bombs you look at
you know how much better kamara has
gotten you look at the mazda fight first
one you know not fun
very boring i could see this fight being
boring camaro could put him against the
cage hold him against the cage do work
get him down there leon gets back up
right in the cage you get a lot of that
for five rounds but tomorrow wins cool
but i i can see in a world where you
know kumar usman fancy himself a striker
wants to prove a point prove he's the
brown champ and lands a big shot on leon
edwards
again leon edwards is a volume guy a
technician
makes very little mistakes in there
but also remember in that fifth round
nate diaz after getting his ass what a
few ten eight rounds there after getting
his ass whooped was allowed to land a
right hand on leon edwards and wobble
him
you're out your goddamn mind if you
don't think karma owes someone hits
harder than leon edwards
camaro lands dude it's problems for leon
edwards easier said than done i could
see it happening but you can also see
karmarushman holding against the cage
for five rounds boring fight
the one i'm keyed
onto and i don't think goes all three
rounds is polycasta luke rockhold
i think paul acosta comes out like a
goddamn banshee i think luke gets him
down and luke is
you guys haven't seen it i'm [ __ ]
telling y'all luke on the ground
especially on top is a [ __ ]
nightmare the best of the middleweight
division
the of nightmare dude and then luke wins
this one it's off to the races being a
former champ even though he hasn't had a
win in a hot second he's lost to some
tough [ __ ] guys
you know i i'm just curious you know
he's pretty outspoken
you know he's lost his last two he's
three out of his last four um you know
but one lost the bisping for the
middleweight championship he beat david
branch lusty old romero romero you know
came in way overweight won the
championship um he did ko'd in that and
then the ko against yon taking you know
an entire year off and come back
fighting yawn nothing hanging your head
on you i'm you know world champion so
doing something right so um
you know i think luke does have to watch
his p's and q's earlier in that fight
man
he has to do that otherwise he's getting
some trouble with polikas he does hit
like a mack truck but
to that extent paul acosta has lost his
last two
so if he in a rhythm of losing fights
and not capitalizing and he lost the
victoria fight for sure um you know he
lost the izzy fight so
he had dealt with in that izzy fight but
he did beat joel romero and stuff like
that so
i just think luke
if he can avoid the big punches early on
as this fight goes on if it was five
rounds definitely i'd take i would bet
my house on luke but he just has to
avoid getting hit in those first two
rounds especially that first round luke
has got to avoid that has to use his
wrestling
his wrestling's good but it's not a he's
not bo nickel you know what i'm saying
he's not kamar gusman but he he's good
enough to get
um
homeboy down so i i do think luke fights
smart he realizes what's on the table
but again
for luke listen i like guys that cause a
[ __ ] storm i like guys that talk [ __ ] to
the ufc i think it's fun it's
entertaining you know him talking about
fighting and making some points on you
know the 50k bonus everyone say oh 50k
but the ufc has grown how are we still
on 50k bonus and guys that are excited
about it it's a fair point
now that being said i don't know if ufc
wants their champ being that guy i
wouldn't be surprised if this ends up
hurting him even if he knocked paulo
costa out in three seconds with a head
kick best ko we've ever seen i don't
think ufc gives him a title shot
because one of the downsides of talking
that [ __ ] which he is which i appreciate
you talk that [ __ ] ufc and discipline
you
you have to walk through [ __ ] fire
before you become a world champion
before they give you the opportunity
so we'll see what happens
fun fight though two fight campaigns on
saturday you're crazy brendan say less
say less team is working
casey's piss you can't play goal
oh you can for sure dog
all right what else you got you
all ready let's go to a few retirements
here
yeah
uh nina nunez retired rory mcdonald yep
my boy retired i think he was checked
out long before this i feel the same way
too well he was checked out but yeah
yeah i watched that fight live it was um
right before the the ufc prelims on
fight night san diego
you know
and also uh rory just the the speed's
not there anymore
um
but rory's not a sad story you know i
there's a lot of pressure on rory to be
the next gsp and it's just talking about
lightning in a bottle when comes gsp you
know but he was supposed to be the
savior of canada when jsb retired so it
was a lot going on with him
yeah
you're right hall retired today as well
uh it's with great sadness are we still
away from the greatest sport in the
world i'm going to miss the crowbc staff
has become like family and the mentors
i've met along the way uc give me the
best opportunity to step completely
outside my comfort zone
throughout the years i've gone up
against some of the best and we're at
the highest level although i did not
achieve the rank of world champion i've
acquired some of my greatest
achievements he did beat uh gegard musa
uh
i was facing my fears becoming a
champion in life i want to thank the
incredible fans using my support words
today it's important to have the right
people around you that take care of you
encourage you to become a better version
of yourself i want to thank my team my
coaches my friends family lastly i want
to thank dana white for giving an
opportunity to collide with modern day
gladiators thank you for always
supporting me through good or bad to the
next generation you are the top one
percent of greatest athletes on the
planet i disagree uh it will be a
pleasure to watch where you all take the
support from here we'll be watching go
forth
praying emoji
yeah you're out how's an instrument he's
straining with us that reign has all the
[ __ ] skill in the world but for him
it was up here yeah there's always a
fight inside of his mind because he has
a skill set to be anybody in the world
anybody in the world
yeah so he lost his last two and then
called it quits
if you remember him he's another guy
that had a lot of pressure on him
because
remember his uh heel spinning heel kick
knockout on ultimate fighter and dan was
like he's like ash and silva and we're
like jesus christ
and then you know the ufc is just a
different animal
he he had his ups and downs but overall
good career meant great career
split decision losses to calvin gaslum
john howard
beat thiago santos
big guard mousasi
big jocko
beat anderson silva chris weidman he has
some big wins man yeah
but yeah i mean again another guy
similar rory mcdonald we put this
pressure all this pressure on these guys
and remember this is back in the day too
when he won the ultimate fighter it was
off to the [ __ ] races now the ufc is
learning they learned what darren till
ruined darren till they learned you look
at what they do with sugar shawn patty
like they're kind of taking their time
on guys now
but yeah shout out good luck in
retirement you're at home you're such a
nice guy
rory mcdonald too man it's family kid
two daughters i think yeah like he has a
great family yeah great guy
um i thought this was pretty interesting
so this is the salaries for the the ufc
san diego
and
let's see here
angela hill actually made more than uh
cheeto
yeah oh no maybe more than dominic cruz
but that's her show and win so 95 grand
to a show 95 grand a win yeah i'm cured
but dominic cruz would have made a lot
more than everybody if he would have won
that's the game
that's the game yeah just interesting
yeah but if you would have won you know
yeah you gotta win that's the game you
know dana did that gq interview and they
were talking about fighter pay and he
was like i mean what do you want me to
do he said i think we pay guys fairly of
course he's gonna say that and this is
what people should note is he also said
pay the pay change will never happen as
far as
when i'm alive
they get quite the hurdle jump just so
dan white said was asked gq interview
over concerns about low fighter pay he
goes you always have something to [ __ ]
about i guess these guys get paid what
they're supposed to get paid
and then jake paul who's been infamous
going at dana goes no major sport
organization pays his athletes as poorly
as dana white and ufc if you don't see
that then you're one of dana's sheeps
they keep talking about selling out 21
events in a row but never talking about
raising fighter pay giving them health
care and fair revenue split yeah he's
right i think danny's gonna be surprised
the pressure that
comes forward the more people learn
about the pay
again i quit talking about the pay i
don't know the ins and outs i don't know
their overhead um it appears you know i
think they pay out it's almost 20
percent of their overall gross
i don't know i i it seems like they
could afford to pay
i
more i legit don't know though
look at the numbers again i don't know
all their overhead and all that [ __ ]
yeah
people are like oh pay casey or mark
morgan you don't know my overhead dog
there you go you know what i'm saying
i think you guys are paid what you're
supposed to get paid
so sam elvis he was on aeroshow and he
was he's been vocal about
not criticizing the pay he says like
he's happy with the payment he said
like when he started
that level it's been going up
incrementally so when he started
what was it like the headliners now
the headliners back then he's making
more money than
they did back then so it's going up you
know somewhat listen it's just their
business model you know you eat what you
kill
you what you kill so when you look at
that and like yo donald cruz got paid
less than angela lee or whatever you're
like yeah man you gotta win
you lose you hit angela hill yeah
angela's one championship uh
you know
i don't know i feel 20 pretty low
yeah
and the thing is i could understand if
the league was doing bad but they had
their biggest year ever every year is
bigger than the next you know they're
shining all these deals
but
it's just dana and the ufc is getting
fatter well the fighters now the the
they point and go well look at what
connor makes like it could be with like
no i know the outliers well what's
that's what they bring in yeah so yeah
and even they're not compensated those
guys are crunk about it because they're
making more money than god but really if
you look at how much they're worth the
company they should be they're underpaid
yeah
i agree
it's like if you look at what joe rogan
got paid from spotify you look at how
much the company's revenue went up how
much their net worth went up in stock
you'd say got grossly underpaid
company's
over billions of dollars now since he
jumped on board like hell but they paid
him 100 million it's like no i know
that's a lot of money but
if you look at the actual numbers you
break down black and white he got
underpaid
you like connor i would imagine what
conor means to the ufc the amount of
fights he's brought in the biggest
pay-per-view star of all time i would be
willing to bet he's underpaid
true not
the the key thing that was dan was like
as long as i'm alive you'll never see a
change in fighter paper oh he's not even
open to it
this ain't happening
he always says like if you want to pay
him more then you start your own
uh league right hand i kind of respect
that he said cool start your own league
how how are these other leagues doing
and the leagues are like we're going to
pay 50 they're in business for one year
affliction was like we're going to do
what's right you know damn's all say
less and then a year later they're out
of business so
it's hard to argue because he they have
you know they got the best show in town
you know they're paying the fighters
what they think is what they should pay
him and they they create major stars you
know
you can have affliction uh is barnett
freaking or no bro josh brought out for
one of the companions i guess not a bad
idea good to hit them up
all right um
here
yuri prahashka and glover texter their
rematch is in talks for ufc 282 in this
this december so end of the year i'll
take it take my money
and that's a t-mobile arena
and some other fight announcements juror
cannonier versus sean strickland oh
that's a fun fight fight night main
event both coming off losses
huge fight for both these guys mm-hmm
you lose that one you're tough to get
back in the queue for a title shot
indeed another one jacker mansion derek
brunson that's fun for december 3rd yeah
and let's see here
i already know that sam lv is not no
longer with the efc yeah after the nine
something losses
um
this was weird so tyson fury last week
on a tuesday sadie's have he's doing a
comeback he wants to fight derek jusora
and
he even like did an instagram thing with
his new trainer talking about the
trainer and literally like a few days
later he says he's decided to retire
again so i see this i i figured he was
retired and then his promoter was like
no he's not retired you know him versus
joshua would be still one of the biggest
fights we need to do he's got to fight
joshua if only was for free so clearly
that's not happening and he posts a
picture he's like to celebrate my
retirement i bought this he brought an
f8 ferrari tributeo spider same car i
have
i'm telling you man for i keep telling
people this like you fit in that thing
i'm telling you man
tyson fury i know my [ __ ] cars tyson
fury's big ass fits in it so i fit
perfect he fits good in it i don't know
if you have to get special seats made
because he is taller but i i don't know
yeah he posted a picture of that uh f8
tribute to spider
saying you know
decided to walk away with he's only 34.
that's so crazy
do you look at him his room too he's
chilling
that's a trip that he's fitting in there
now if you hit the coops with a hard top
little less room but i'm telling you you
eat the spider big boys can fit in it
right side too on this one
and then he loves the dinosaur nugget
chicken fries
like my [ __ ] two-year-old
he's the best that's cool
the best yeah
um so judo jean labelle he passed away i
guess in his sleep natural causes but i
remember him because of uh ronda rousey
him and they were very close him and
were close
you know he's the guy so it says served
as an inspiration for the quentin
tarantino character inspiration sure
that if you talk to jane labelle that is
that's how it went down he [ __ ] dudes
up on set
like guys who thought they were tough
jean lebel's like say les check this out
he was like you know hollywood royalty
he the character in one time in
hollywood my favorite movie of all time
the character brad pitt that [ __ ] up
bruce lee that is from the perspective
of gene labelle apparently that actually
happened
so
rest in peace my man legend
uh this is pretty crazy i think bruce
lee's family's all upset like this is
[ __ ] like really
i mean i don't know what happened oh i
do
i think that's exactly what happened
okay could it happen yeah it's possible
all right so the korean zombie has a gin
in korea and check out what happened
here
holy [ __ ] is that rain yeah i guess like
there's a crazy
like floods and rain in korea god damn
that is a ton of water yeah it's
happening in vegas too like the vegas uh
yeah the casinos got flooded too well i
mean if it's raining in vegas that's
good yeah hopefully no too much floods
but as all dads say we need it yeah
we definitely do we need it anytime we
start writing my dad in denver we need
it i'm like all right dude it's we do
need it i mean
i do we yeah or do we just stop
producing [ __ ] almonds and not have
the drought anymore do we need almonds
that bad i do love almonds though yes
um so kamar usman he's already done the
50 clean tests and all that stuff i
guess once he even started his career
he was tested since that's when usada
came in
so he's upset which i would be too
because he's saying like why would why
do they have to do it at 5 a.m in the
morning
that's when they came knocking on his
door
it is weird especially right before a
fight it's like usada can you not wait
till after 10 a.m to do this guy gets
rest preparing for the base fight of his
life
does it make sense
at least you know they're doing it yeah
i mean the time thing sucks because he
needs his freaking rest stupid
all right let's look at this real quick
so
darren till tweeted at oh didn't tweet
at daniel but tweeted about daniel
cormier i'll just show you the tweet
here
charles islam
what a fight just don't let dc
commentate
you know implying that he's going to be
biased or whatever so then daniel
cormier responded i expect better for me
i called multiple teammates fights and i
say my commentary doesn't affect the
judges or anything honestly
most times my team is mad at me because
they feel i'm too much in the other
direction do better till yeah and then
till responded
i forget who i was talking to i'm sorry
i was drunk oh wait uh what was this
first
i was oh says i was just joking i only
said it for likes and retweets obviously
commentating smiley face yeah he's just
a troll yeah he needs to win fights
though
i know i'm saying it's like that is the
most important thing yeah i was down
with it but
when you haven't want to fight in years
kind of like all right
so you're the the funniest guy on
twitter
that's your gig now
come on dude he wants likes and retweets
so yeah how to do it yeah doing it for
the gram
there's been a lot can we just talk
about that this fight of paulo costa yes
is for the best looking man in the ufc
and best bodies
face bodies all around they got the
whole package yep
dudes are gonna be figuring their
buttholes during this fight this fight
is lit yeah but he's the best body oh my
god these boys they just got bodies for
days
bodies for days
i mean yeah paulo costa said oh luke you
think you're the best looking guy in the
uc hold my bear because my dad's vitor
belfort
that's he is bodied up dude yeah
he looks like not too jacked not like no
bulky he looks like he's kind of slimmed
down a little bit so that's good they
both look good yeah
i don't know if you knew about this yeah
he's looking daddy's the liking
okay i don't know if you knew about this
but i guess uh fight pass now has a
comedy series with this guy
oh adam hunter
i've known adam for years that was a
great comic so he does comedy and i
guess these so far frankie edgar sarah
mcmahon andre touchy feely and gerald
harris they're doing stand-up that's
cool on that show i know woodley has
tried a few times too
yeah let me just play with this real
quick clip of frank edgar let me know
what you think
you know i have more time in yacht guy
than anybody in the history to ufc
[Applause]
i've been punched kicked and beamed down
more than will smith's been beaten by
jada
listen if punches were dicks my face
would look like paige van sant's inbox
that's funny
not bad especially he was just starting
out yeah yeah i did get mad that's cool
this is a cool concept
pretty cool yeah
all right
so you know bj penn was going for
governor oh he lost yeah but he's not
conceding oh very trumpish of him
uh just there's some funny things in
here they're not conceding it's like uh
there wasn't like collusion here it's
not like
yeah i keep going watch this is one of
the things on his honors whatever
agenda
what's up everybody this is dj pan
and i believe oahu needs a drag strip
racetrack just like the big island the
big island has one and oahu needs one
and it's been way too long
what a drag race track
it's always
yeah
that's what we're [ __ ] missing feel
like [ __ ] we can't eat you think we
have a [ __ ] about a drag strip
and then this uh this is okay this is
david
david dj harris jr posted this but then
the comment was funny from stone's mom
uh
so bj payne get rid of corruption so
stone's mom and who knows who this guy
is
uh my husband's friends arrested him
passed out behind the wheel with his
face covered in cocaine and we're still
voting for him because [ __ ] the system
just want to get in and fire the school
superintendent exposed [ __ ] i'll take
that any day over kai kaheli and green
like i said same here even though in his
past we're still voting for him well
apparently not enough people voted i
know there's the poll right there oh my
god they can't be
ten eight rounds
yeah ready second
that sucks i wish you would have won
duke
oh hold on is that a white dude what's
up i mean what oh no he's a hawaiian
[ __ ] duke
bj penn pj's picture looks the most
official heidi just barely got us i mean
yeah five thousand votes we were doing
then gary just doesn't even have a
picture yeah what are we doing gary done
her pick yeah
okay this is uh
another issue with adrian broner he was
supposed to fight this weekend
and
he bailed out saying he has mental some
sort of mental issues going on right now
mental health issues
it's
oh wait
you don't have to read the whole thing
but
he's sorry to his fans blah blah all
that stuff
mental health so he said sorry the fans
about how this is real
and i'm not about to play inside the
ring i've watched a lot of people die
playing the box skirt and i haven't uh
something i won't do just pray for me i
love the sport box too much not to give
my all i feel like i came but short
because my mind wasn't 100
there and i'll be damned if i make that
mistake again i need to make some
changes for better side worry about
other people's feelings please them
and then his opponent is like
mental health is tough to do like if
someone says mental health is like thing
you can't touch you know you're like
well prove it yeah that's exactly all
right well i'm sad
how about that
i'm sad yeah show me how sad what do you
want me to do dude remember sending a
video crying i do actually
uh as we all know my fight against
that mf broner is off now i don't mind
this because something we expect so we
had plans in motion
um what real people have said this mf
wants to use mental health as a effing
excuse that i have a problem with
because that's bs you don't get to cry
mental health now mfr not saying you
don't suffer mental health issues we all
get we can all tell you do just don't
use it as an excuse now after you've
been on discipline not taking this fight
training camp seriously that'd be my
thing that's where my head goes yeah
then he goes if it is really meant to
prove please show proof you went and
sought professional help come on daddy
you know don't work like that that's why
mental health if you get out of anything
it's
what are you gonna do i know and now i'm
not saying he doesn't clearly
have some mental issues but also as a
professional fighter if you're not
disciplined you're overweight and you're
your coach like bro you look like [ __ ]
we gotta pull out of this
you can't say oh i was on discipline and
decided not to take this fight and now
i'm not ready to go you can't do that
so mental health is a good out
you'd love to post all your [ __ ] on
social media why not let us in your
mental health recovery you don't get to
undermine mine and countless other
journeys struggle's mental health
because of your undisciplined child is
dumbass few broner just when i thought
you couldn't stoop any lower
yeah
yeah it's tough
how do you prove it
i know i mean if you had hospital
records that'd be one way but do you
check in the hospital when you're you
know depressed i mean if you're suicidal
you should but if you're just you know
if you have chronic depression yeah i
don't know yeah you probably
i'm with homeboy here where i'm like
dude
come on bro likely on discipline yes
come on
all right um so beau nicole he's been
all the hype recently i'm a fan yeah
biggest prospect in a hot second he won
the his fight in the contender series
but then dana white didn't the second
fight he won the contender series then
dana goes it's not gonna be a contract
yet you gotta fight one more time
i would even say need to fight five to
six seven more times it you know if
we're doing this right
because once you're in the ufc
you better be ready to go man um
you know with bone nickel there's been
some big names they're like you know
he
i don't get the
kind of hate on bo nickel as far as
you know his wrestling pedigree now
was the olympic gold medalist no and did
he make the national team no
but you're talking about
and hold up neither did phil davis you
know did a lot of these great wrestlers
you know how hard is to be an olympic
gold medalist very few henry ceoudo
there's a not many man it's [ __ ]
mission impossible now you're talking
about
one of the greatest collegiate wrestlers
ever
ever in bow nickel now the guy that he
lost to to get on the national team
which isn't in the weight class he
competes at but to get on the team
um you know he lost to david taylor who
i don't know if you know this went on to
win gold also was his training partner
for many of years so they know each
other david it's not like he lost a guy
who didn't make the team either he lost
to the guy so to to to go he's not even
on the olympic team i mean his
wrestling's decent
decent wrestle bow nickel let me know
how it goes for you you're talking about
a he won the heisman for collegiate
wrestling
three-time all-american out of penn
state ever heard of it so for me you
know the the criticism on him as far as
wrestling is just stupid unless you're
you know unless you're jordan burrows
shut your yapper right when it comes to
wrestling right
because you're not drawing burrows all
these guys criticizing him the other
thing is
i'm with and biswing said it best was
like slow your role young man like dude
like the and i agree with all this
criticism it's like
you know he's he's 2-0 on dan white
contender series and it's only two
no he's 2-0 are you sure yeah he's well
i'm sorry 2-0 professional one-on-one
white contender series but two-and-oh so
he only has two professional fights his
longest fight lasted a minute he
destroyed that dude that dude had no
business being in there i assume they
give him a step up in competition in
this next one let's see how he does with
that but even at 3-0 to get in the fc
again bo it it's such a
marathon not a sprint i would like if he
went outside that and competed because
just camping on the contender says isn't
really the way to go
also if he's like i don't want to do
that i just want to be you know doing my
ufc thing cool if i'm dana make him the
face the contender series make him give
make a container series champion have
bone nickel get experience on the
contender series and guys have to get
through him to get to the ufc not a bad
test but also you got a superstar bow
nickel is the biggest prospect we've had
in [ __ ] years
huge prospect huge prospect so
i mean this this
dana white contender series is really
blowing up people dig it destroys the
ultimate fighter now not even close not
even close i mean i can't believe
anybody watches ultimate fighter i don't
know if people do watch ultimate fighter
i know people watch dan white contender
series i know big bow nickel is a huge
[ __ ] name also can you ima can you
name the last time a guy in
contemporary's got this much attention
why not make him the face of it make him
the champion of uh the contender series
and then have him graduate to the ufc so
the fan base grows with him but to have
a guy who's 3-0 fighting ufc and really
wrestling grappling is his pedigree and
that's it it's tough man
it's tough
because there are guys at that ufc level
who aren't even in the top 30 who can
defend and take down from a world-class
wrestler and make it [ __ ] miserable
the the ufc especially this day and age
just being a wrestler ain't gonna get it
done now there are guys who
if you look at the uc champions you look
at people successfully ufc they
specialize in one thing really how
dominant could be with was his wrestling
you know but nicole's could be that
maybe i don't know but
signing the ufc uh a six-fight contract
at even if he destroys which he will
soon
on uh dan white cathedral days at 3-0
man
man man man i would like a little more
experience out of them but for guys like
how he wasn't even that good of a
wrestler and just what
you [ __ ] kidding me dude look at his
goddamn
record at penn state man they're going
to build a [ __ ] statue of this man
he's a freak dude and that mentality if
if bow nick is a stock i'm all in and
you're talking to a guy who didn't
[ __ ] touch crypto
or bitcoin while you guys were sucking
them off now your your money's cut in
half when it was the hype thing to do i
didn't invest in it all right
but bo nickel i'm all in dude they but
i'm all in depending
how the ufc wants to treat him i don't
make him the champion of uh dean white
contender series get let say once you
get to 10 fights win lose or draw 10
fights we're going to put promo into you
you're going to build a fan base fans
are going to follow you then we're going
to graduate you to the ufc you go 10
10-0 on dan white contender series then
we get to ufc
we're going sizzler daddy 10-0 give him
some good competition if he does get
beat that guy automatically hits the ufc
but also there's way more pressure on
the contender series too than him
fighting these regional circuits you
know like that that's a big boy
production dana white's there ringside
you're the face of it to me that makes
more sense
that one's on the house ufc
but i'm all in on bow nickel yeah best
prospect we've had since [ __ ] uh
a hot second hot hot second trying to
think
what's his face over in bellator oh my
god oh aaron pico aaron pico yeah
the bo nico with his wrestling
background
and he's training from a big boy camp
he's at att everyone says he's a savage
dude savage
apparently like he doesn't look like it
but strength wise he's a [ __ ] freak
he's like to me he's like a little mini
dan henderson
oh i miss anderson
hendo hendo is the best yeah i loved him
um okay so
dana white on that same gq q a series he
did uh his top five fighters of all time
and then he named off jon jones anderson
silva ronda rousey conor mcgregor gsp
did they say give me five or they just
said you know what i'm saying it's the
top five yeah
i'm assuming the problem here people
have is he doesn't have khabib in it
yeah
which i thought was a little weird too
well
obviously the guy interviewed him
doesn't know [ __ ] about it they're
answering questions from twitter so
someone on twitter asked
gotcha but i would appreciate
going through that list
it'd be tough to have ronda rousey in
there as top five
of all time man or woman now is she the
number one most important
you know uh mo top five female fighter
100
but as far as
straight up wins losses
longevity
all that [ __ ] you're more
more than kumar hussman
20-1 he's about to break anderson
silva's title record defense
you know so it's all again because he's
the you know dana white [ __ ] star the
ufc knows and sold it for a 2 gillion
dollars it's important but you know i
would like to know what his criteria is
for top five
some of those guys you can't have in
there again
i would the only one i agree with on
this entire lit well i agree with three
of them jon jones
uh answering sylvan gsb rondo and connor
top five of all time again what is your
criteria for top five he does mention
usman should be on there but then that
gets out of the five that he's saying
the first five he looks i i just when
you talk about actual
wins and losses and
um
overall career in the ufc i just don't
know how you'd put ronda and connor over
usman or khabib exactly you know
conor could be bought right and one beat
the other one and then for ronda um you
know how would you not have amanda nunes
in over her they
fought right so
but again maybe he's thinking of like
top five that changed the sport and then
yeah that's that's gonna make more sense
jon jones i would love to hear an
argument how he's not number one oh pd
shot it i'm talking about straight up
black and white wins and losses best
ever do it fought the toughest
competition over time at the most
dangerous weight class in the world it's
jon jones hands down
shoeing
and silva i get especially as hey you
know gsp get um
yeah i'd have to know what his criteria
is you know
yeah
but yeah khabib and camaro should be in
there
and i believe that's pretty much it
let's look at this real quick how he
blew the blew up again oh yes he did
what yeah i think he said he's 200 right
now
oh this is him when he walked into the
ufc san diego
[Applause]
just a huge star man i mean he's night
and day from when he's fighting to i
mean look at the same person i know i
love it
to me i love it i can't get enough of it
liverpool's original thick boy man the
fifth thick beetle yeah
is that it that's it
all right kids well fights here you got
some big boy fights coming up again
cowbest fight campaign on a thick boy
youtube you can watch lemonade pacific
live our first uh cowbest fight
companion for bkfc 27 it's in london you
got michael venom page coming on over
from fricken bellator to face
just the dog of all dogs
mike perry who's undefeated and bare
knuckles he's only had one fight but
you know this fight uh is exciting man
and for that fight companion you have
bert kreischer the machine ever heard of
him matt matrion and myself breaking all
down watching the fights sipping some
whiskey at 11 a.m in the morning on
saturday um and then for the co-main
event you have paige van zandt also
fighting
and uh what'd you say sigalia yep
friends tagala uh good fights man i'm
excited for it once you got a little
promo yeah let's get legit get me crunk
for this chin
i'm the one only mvp michael venom page
entertaining unusual unique i like to do
stuff that doesn't necessarily make
sense
[Music]
i think i'm one of the toughest man on
the planet it may not always be pretty
but damn it you can't beat me we'll see
if he ever comes forward at all
i want to go in there i want to land
shots and not be touched i'm more a
sniper like i said man if he's there at
the end of it well he'll be bleeding
[Music]
[Music]
there you have it this saturday michael
venom page
mike perry it is going down cowbest
fight campaign 11am pacific time
we will be watching with bert kreischer
and matt mitrione and myself
i cannot wait for that man this bare
knuckles fun it's really fun that's fun
and then later that night 7 p.m pacific
guest to be announced some very special
guests you guys can be crunk for this
man we have cowboys fight command for
ufc 278 in salt lake city utah
you have freaking tyson pedro jose aldo
paulo casa luke rockhold that's your
co-main event the main event camaro
usman the pound for pound number one in
the world vs leon edwards the freaking
britons on a 10 fight win streak they
fought before but both guys have gotten
better i can't freaking wait tune in 7
p.m pacific time thick boy youtube
you also got god dang it's a busy
weekend daddy you also got anthony
joshua versus you usyk um you know using
before i was for anthony joshua i really
hope joshua gets the [ __ ] together so he
fights tyson fury even though tyson
fury's
running amuck like wreck-it ralph and
his f8 ferrari and [ __ ] london right
now but hopefully that fight happens but
you got a lot going on this weekend man
uh enjoy the fights i will see you guys
saturday at 11 a.m for the bare knuckle
fighting cowbest fight companion with
bert kreischer and i'll also see you at
7 p.m on saturday for the ufc 278
cowboys fight companion with very
special guests then i'll also see you in
chicago one night only den theater on
the 26th one night one show only that
[ __ ] will sell so get tickets right now
it's not a big theater that's den
theater downtown chicago august 26th
that's a friday at 7 30 one show only
the trash panda summer tour continues
then on the 27th i'm running the tough
mudder you can sign up right now if you
go to
fatkz.com you'll see the link for the
tough mudder on the 27th that's a
saturday use promo code team brendan for
10 off and then uh back on tour starts
september 8th through the 10th appleton
wisconsin appleton wisconsin the skyline
comedy club there
my favorite people in the business run
and own those clubs that's appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
ontario improv ontario baby i'm staying
in town ontario improv um that is
september 15th through the 17th then i
end september in boston when my favorite
place is on the [ __ ] planet so my
son's name boston boston is september
29th through october 1st at laugh boston
baby tickets at fatkz.com or
thickboy.com i will see you this
saturday for bkfc 11 a.m with burt
kreischer and i also see you at 7 p.m on
think boy youtube for ufc 278 calabasas
fight companion that's it be nice to
each other stay thick see you saturday
you